le parti dachnak madame lagarde
oui cctv je crois qu'il est arrivé car
c'est un nouveau truc des émissions
c'est un mec m'a rencontrant ce pack
east et une cagoule et ce sont les
autres
[Applaudissements]
salut la cagoule
j m quel choix tu tiens je dirais que ça
dépend d éviter ces internes
c'est en quelque sorte et quelques
questions à l'esprit vous concernant il
apparaîtrait que ce deuxième disque aux
prises deux roues qui s'appelle aurait
peut-être moins de succès que le premier
appelé estadistica l'oci le troisième eh
ben c'est peut-être les statistiques
pour qu' il faut savoir question
effectivement été un succès plus que
plus qu'estivale et que pour l'instant
le deuxième 45 tours et après disque
d'or déjà donc ça fait pas autant
d'effets comme ça mais comme moi je suis
reste discrète sur ses trucs sur les
scellés décoration les remises de machin
- tu sais ça fait partie d'un album
alors il faut aussi concevoir la chose
détiennent et c'est un peu isolé
maintenant cela sont plus en groupe
combien de 45,4 m on va avoir chez pas 4
ou 4,5 puisqu'il veut savoir ceux ci le
troisième à moins de succès le deuxième
début - tu le sais que le premier est ce
que tu vas très bien attirer les 45 et
33 tours en raison disent parce qu'on ne
sait pas tout à fait vrai qu'ils ont
occupée
on verra bien mais à mon avis ça va
avoir le cul sec
l'autre est il faut appeler la rue on
appelle à la lutte est donc pour passer
d'un sujet à un autre scellier vous pour
la légalisation de certaines herbes
magiques qui peuvent cependant aider à
supporter des contraintes différentes du
quotidien malige en outre marie jeanne
outre l'extension ou parce que je sais
pas mauvaise mais ils ont fait le plus
beau voyage et de regretter je crois
même
maintenant j'ai peur mais ça a un sens
interdit et
non faut pas pauvres voilà la cocaïne
non plus à la sauce états unis
heureusement que c'est plus sympathique
de pouvoir justement la voix rendue à
ses côtés casal lui c'est bien des cas
chez ses pairs il peut se permettre de
tomber parce qu'il est caché justement
cacher ou au grand jour c'est ce qui
vous intéresse de savoir si dans votre
entourage il y à des êtres qui ont des
pulsions est actuel profonde
d'après mes livres c'est actuelle et
êtes vous pour les relations
homosexuelles à moi je prends toutes les
relations ça se vend pas sur le coup
tout ça et il faudrait d'ailleurs qu'on
arrête de parler de sas au coude avec
lui qui se charge d'expliquer ma
sexualité
euh non
non j'aurais j'aurais j'aurais dit oui
de chauffe pas trop
avant c'était moi qui peut ce genre de
rythme j'ai fait la marque aussi
l'arrivée c'est mon côté je suis plus
avec lui alors il est très bien apprise
il tire même certaines bleus honteux
comme ça à eux
ppda aux crêtes oui oui et guillaume du
lens oui avec lesquels aimeriez vous
passer aux levés quant à moi si j'étais
obligé oui oui amélioration du nord avec
duran duran avec ses plus mince et
répondant aux craintes elle ne dit rien
et où non savait pas sexuellement et oui
voilà tu vois pas faire attention c'est
pda le pont alors c'est pas du tout tu
vois si avec une cagoule non plus à la
non encore moins non ça je suis pas
genre
maintenant la lumière non plus avant sa
taille et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de nos latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux